is it like [ __ ] you just live in a
house for [ __ ] a well pump or what
yeah we have to wear the headphones
if you want I do one we're alive right
now yeah just yelling at [ __ ] fell
we're here with this is the board
the board of Catan
uh we will be worshiping for the next
two hours
until somebody wins
more than likely
there is a good amount of sheep on the
board sheep are very high probability
rolls good amount of brick not a lot of
Rock
very few Rock
wow
so such as the boards the mother of
katana spoken
this is what we're doing is your friend
that dice no no I never found the dice
that seems like a really critical part
oh they're in the dice Cup oh great I
forgot about seven
here we go
I got a four [ __ ] me
five do you have shot glasses
uh no no okay so this is a lot of steps
am I just gonna be taking pulls out of
this though all right I got 10.
so who got the highest number fill up I
think
foreign
how are you doing today
pretty good
what did you do
uh I moved all my [ __ ]
thank God you did that
yeah it was very productive day
I'm glad that you moved you moved
recently to another house
um
no
are you good what is there to explain
yeah move he didn't move you just moved
[ __ ] general what happened nothing other
than that
well it's like a boulder move the
boulder yeah I moved my favorite Boulder
about like three feet whose turn is it
five okay
pushing a boulder is fun every now and
then
wait I got a four are we going by
counterclockwise or are we going by yes
all right
DF asks what's a conservationist
what a conversationalist
oh
thank you thank you so what do you guys
think about the abortion ban
or the abortion Roe v Wade being
overturned
oh it's super for it
yeah what else what yeah I mean bus
rides for women right
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up all right
what if I want to put it okay
why would you do that huh because I was
trying to put it to your stupid face
okay well it is pretty stupid but
um
where's the trunk of it is okay
no put it on first
I don't know oh clamp it yeah
that's probably the smarter idea it's
not the clump
yeah that's not the clamp God
so what do you guys think about Gareth
is he improving I think he's a really
solid argument for the abortion ban
I mean against the abortion band yeah
I swear I can figure this out
I feel like if you're gonna make jokes
about killing fetuses
you got to stick the landing on the
punch line
you can't quit halfway
and end up with an aborted fetus yeah of
a joke yeah I almost aborted that
microphone that was definitely don't
tighten it
because you're going to want to move it
right yeah so untighten it I get that
you're moving the whole thing sure but
I'm talking from here not that one you
didn't tighten that one though yeah
that's the one you tightened oh all
right I'm untied it all right that
better yeah well clearly I can get this
up to my face all right make sure you
re-tighten it though yeah it looks like
it's slipping around
that's not what you tighten tighten the
bottom I did I think it's it's pretty
good it's on there no it's not trying
this it's still moving around shut up
all right look it's going
you're retaining it the right way it's
not on 90 degrees right now I know that
dude it's a little too late to get it to
the correct angles
no it's not it's never too late fix it
are you doing all right Gary
you look like you're missing a lot of
blood in your favorite are you doing
okay
yeah I mean
oh you worked out yeah yeah
nice I did and then I immediately ate a
bunch of Italian food
so I feel pretty good but not really
yeah I want the high probability
of this number over here is that all
right appropriate
I had to judge my desert decision
who am I hearing right now
that's the devil
so do you think that Texas Austin Texas
is going to be the new comedy capital
hell yeah King let's go dude
represent that's why I see it I mean you
can kind of like
already is
what
they're strong those are fighting words
in some places I would assume
those are fighting words yeah [ __ ] words
oh what are we gonna do to me are you
gonna fight you dude they're gonna fight
me he's gonna fight you dude I'm gonna
kick my ass
I can only assume
I hope not dude I hope not too dude I
can't fight at all I I don't believe
that below I bet you can fold your own
fist fight with a couple homeless people
man I'm a huge [ __ ]
you're no you're not man wait you're
just a lover you're the lover not a
fighter it's clear yeah
yeah I'd do the same thing I'm not
trying to fight anybody either is it my
turn this turn is it it's your turn it's
your turn man sorry
gonna grab those uh yeah
Phil what the [ __ ] you do today man
uh I woke up kind of early for for what
I do and then I went to work at two
but before that I got into an argument
with my mechanic that's holding on to my
moped right now because they tried to
charge me 400 to do a valve adjustment
and they're holding it uh well they just
like I turned it in for an oil change
and like what's it do for a valve
adjustment and all this stuff and I was
like okay well if it's do it's too and
they call me back they wanted to say
like we're gonna do four hours of work
which is going to be 470 and I was like
I'll do it at home and watch YouTube
and they did it they just did the work
no no they called to verify with me they
were holding it for the part that they
were gonna put on so all together
everything was going to be like 800 turn
again
so how good it's just a bad day all
together no I'm gonna pay them 90 for a
stupid oil change for a moped which is
more than my car cost to get
yeah my car's [ __ ] too babe I'm never
doing it again I'm just gonna do it all
you charged me too much for this oil
change [ __ ] you guys
yeah
yeah
that's a dude oil change is [ __ ]
expensive now dude from moped it's one
quart of oil okay that's true all right
I don't know [ __ ] about it and it's one
10 millimeter socket bolt it should take
them maybe 15 minutes but that's I'm not
400 no they were charging 90 for the oil
change and ninety dollars they also said
that it was two quarts and I know for a
fact it's one how hard is it to be
yourself
I just did it because I didn't want to
do it where I'm living I don't have like
a garage space and I want to get oil
everywhere and then since it was a valve
adjustment needed I was like I'm not
doing that at home because I don't know
enough about motorcycles yet so
uh is it my turn now or are we getting
back the other way it's gareth's turn
now gotcha no other way to uh
learn about oh wait oh I gotta place my
[ __ ] damn
I worked on cars going out and stuff but
like
everything on the moped has like been
different did you try to hack it with
them at all when they said it was 90
bucks
um
today they quoted me because I was just
like ah don't worry just give me the
part that you're gonna put on I'll
figure out how to put the hose on for
the coolant by myself
and I'll do the valve adjustment by
myself
just do the oil change
so I don't have to mess with them like
do with the mess but sometimes if you
like if you go to a place and they say
like which is expensive and you like
flash a gun
you get a discount
this is a root and tooting in Texas
podcast right now abortions and guns
dude what's better than guns Hans do you
have new guns do you have any guns right
now yeah I have one gun
what is it yeah what is that noise it
sounds like an accordion someone's
playing Call of Duty that is a Google
system setting up like uh it's testing
out how far the speakers are from it and
stuff like that no way yeah it's a smart
system
your mom's a smart system yeah it sounds
like a Death Race
they're brown
I'm catching I'm catching Call of Duty
or something from our neighbors
maybe this has to do with you stealing
your neighbor's internet wait wait it's
stolen they don't know you're doing it
no they know that's nice
it sounds like it's in this room
oh Brian's just testing out his speakers
right now for whatever reason it works
really well those are good speakers
Brian
those are really good
all right and we are that's a homing
theater system that's the [ __ ]
oh let's see Hans is spreading out
he's gonna try the try comb method shut
the [ __ ]
11. that's
wait
you're confused
this alcohol yeah oh thanks
no problem anytime ball that's such a
good sound I'm like
a little bit of that my favorite radio
DJ from back home Russ Martin used to
drink that hammered on the radio every
day for like four to nine and then he
went to like jail briefly because he
pistol whipped his ex-wife in like his
front lawn in South Lake Texas if uh
that tracks if you're getting drunk at
four in the morning
either way either way you're getting
hammered for five hours did you pick up
your last settlement oh yeah I gotta do
that thanks
for their own place
yeah yeah
no sheep dude
oh that's a solid first yeah then
all right whose turn is it where's he's
going to take my hands
my turn
that's uh fails he got first yeah that's
right we're now starting
nine
I forgot
and so uh hanza what does it feel like
to be a gun owner in Texas now
feels very cool you know I'm excited to
come home because I know the gun is
there and it's like a little toy
and I'm like I feel safe with it and I
know it's just a toy would you get like
a Glock I got a glock like clone
huh wait wait hold on it looked well
like a yeah what is it Shadow systems
mr920l okay
hell yeah dude
sorry I was interesting yeah it's fun
yeah I'm done
I'll pass the dice we don't get our
first house or our first house that's it
to me or goes to Hans dude put it put
the cup in the thing sorry
unforgivable dude
seven what did you roll Phil I forgot
what that was a cool sound though
what did you roll nine
nine nine damn she fine
I don't have no nines turns out
damn good time
oh
stop saying the first half of my name
give me give it the Back cast all right
you say this person if I'll say the
second half
wait let's do that one more time
[Laughter]
oh that's solid we got you good is it my
turn
no it's not oh Hans
what are you doing dude
in the chat
how did you do that
four
oh yeah give me some sheep
you know a sheet I'm gonna trade in
these bad boys for a development card in
my turn
so I played a lot on the line
yet still have
not won a game
I think I am Owen
700 or something at this time in my life
with Katan
all right well we're gonna it's gonna
happen
I'm hopeful
as long as you're having fun that's all
that matters
it's a good strategy game
six sorry about the salami
damn
where's the other six under the robber
I'm pretty sure right yeah
I feel like you knew that and you just
wanted me to say it
I just wanted to make sure the tiles
were right
nine oh man
nines are hot
he had lucky for Holland nothing but
noise anyone want wheat
for what brick
sorry Rick economy's not doing so right
now what about wood for Brick or a rock
wood fabric yeah like you have wood yeah
no I don't have any bird or a rock
No One's Gonna Have rock this sometimes
[Music]
not a bit that's true oh yeah The Rocks
locations are not good
12 11 and 2.
it's not a problem
we got a 10. I'm gonna run down and get
this
Phil you get a wood
you're red
what are you doing dude you're ruining
the video stream
open the door
thank you
so what do you think about the whole uh
Creek in the cave versus the Vulcan
situation
is there a situation is there like some
kind of beef or something no there's not
a beef but it's just an interesting
scenario where
they got different clubs and different
ways of doing things we have I mean
isn't it the same like when you go to
New York and you go to like Greenwich
Village and there's like a bunch of
comedy clubs in the same block basically
yeah
I don't really like
well in Greenwich Village there's a
Greenwich Village comedy club which is
like sort of you know it's like
not that popular but it gets a lot of
people because of the location and if
you're at uh the comedy seller
you're like oh we can't go there anyways
let's go here
but I don't think it's that prestigious
I'm just giving it example I'm gonna
steal a card from you Holland places in
close proximity to each other but I
think like I don't know if those guys
like how are you gonna do that
I'm gonna take a card for me yeah you're
playing your night yeah when did you get
that I got that on my first turn
wait what did you roll guys
foreign
pretty much every day
it's more accessible
it's a fun place to hang out
Drake is my home yeah but I love the
Vulcan I mean there's nothing wrong with
either one of the places I don't think I
know there was a beef but yeah
you just stirring [ __ ] up aren't you
Hans I'm not saying there's beef I'm
just saying what do you think about the
differences yeah oh the difference is um
like
well I'm not performing at the whole
thing I feel like it's mostly like the
atmosphere
you want water
I'll take water
this paper bag was a really good choice
too this
is
uh I got everyone water
water
we're balling
let's move some water balloon
gotta stay hydrated is it your turn
below
um
yeah I
what were the numbers that were rolling
I'm gonna build the road nothing
we didn't roll
we were just waiting for you
they want to build a road uh
that's it
I mean these
it's just for you nine again
go for it
yeah there's this gallery
coming from because you can't hear it if
you take off your headphones
I brought the I brought the supplies
sausage
God damn it he [ __ ] cheated
yeah you did you yeah you [ __ ] did I
don't know what you're talking about you
totally
piece of [ __ ] you [ __ ] did you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I just remembered oh you [ __ ] liar
dude
I mix them up
okay go ahead Gary
foreign
wow
[Music]
these uh colors
we got [ __ ] loaded dice don't you
hunt
as if
God [ __ ] apologize
[Music]
so what do you think about
thank you
I like that it's shaping the room too
nine again
nine again and so oh what a Twist can't
do anything
you'll have an IMAX theater
who's nine again seriously um
okay you know what I'm gonna put it on
the nine don't
that's not how probability works
thank you sir
thank you thank you
what is that
what'd you take it's a wheat oh I don't
need that
what's up with the Elon Musk monkey
videos anybody know about that the
advertisements on the bus yeah
apparently he experimented with monkeys
yeah I saw the okay are you coming with
the narrow length thing yeah are you
done Phillip yeah I'm done pass the dice
I have not been able to do [ __ ]
so maybe those monkeys deserve
don't say that three
is mad though
me too hey I mean
he said he'd release the Cyber truck he
hasn't done that
anyone want wood
for what brick no
what about two word for Brick okay
over here
don't do deals with Hans wow that's
racist yeah
same thing as racism no it's not it's
just automatically assuming
no because you [ __ ] win
a lot and then on top of that well Hans
was crazy you're a [ __ ] cheater
did she I know you [ __ ] cheated how
else did you know there's a [ __ ] rock
was there dude I didn't I mixed it yeah
exactly that's why I sat in this seat
that's what I'm saying like I got here I
was like I'm sitting over here when I'm
still I'm still in last place
it's been nines the entire game this
hasn't been even like variety to play on
it
seven s and nines consistently sevens
and knives
something
spread them Hans
which one pot Mill or bottom
something about
no no you [ __ ] spread it off that's
the rules
[ __ ] you dude [ __ ] no spread them no
I'm not down you can't because the rock
hard to swallow your [ __ ] food
because the rock hard is a lightest
color you know which color The Rock card
is
yeah I didn't know I didn't [ __ ] know
that so what no no you're gonna give me
the opportunity now no I'm not I bet I
still can't pick the card out I you know
that that's probably true it's so
obvious top middle or bottom
no I'm not doing that because you're
just gonna change I'm gonna show the
camera
all right you go to the camera
you've traced the cards out and I'll
tell you which one yeah right here
tell me about him no no put your put the
cards out right now put all your cards
out about it I want to count how many
cards you have before the start what's
going on in the chat right now I have
three cars
the education in Texas is lacking too
it's spread them education is dumb I
don't know about it I'm gonna go
yeah
no but we [ __ ] you dude it's such
[ __ ]
middle right here oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude I hate you so much dude
anyone can do that [ __ ]
all right I had my turn y'all almost
kissed
no did you not see the [ __ ] coming out
of his mouth
how long has that burrito been sitting
there dude
believe it
eight
eight
doesn't work
um
just a couple we only have one left
[Music]
oh finally
oh my goodness
those sour the the sour skittles they
never failed to cut the roof of my mouth
yeah that's why I don't eat deep dish
pizza
dish pizza you've never cut your mouth
on some deep dish pizza no
if it's got like really
crispy sides I can I think that's pretty
good that's I that's an interesting fact
that I've just now learned I've burned
the [ __ ] out of my mouth with pizza
that's happened
a change in Direction
going God knows where
because Jesus said no you know you made
the wrong move if you wanted to build
right here you could have just built one
road right here and you'd be right there
yeah or you could go all the way over
here and then it'd be quicker to blow
the road here and here
we decided to build a road here which is
the long way to both places that you
could possibly get why not just connect
it and then build the settlement because
it's a shorter you don't have to spend
as much time waiting for resources at
the beginning
um
yeah Clay is scarce
anyways
are you done yeah unless I can move it
over now
ah you should learn
that's why I told him it's because he
couldn't move it over
there
yeah
I mean
I think it's
maybe it's better if you're preventing
someone from 11.
cutting you off 11. everyone gets
something but me
pick up Philip
no
12. oh [ __ ] you Hans hell yeah
I had to open my stupid mouth
um
so where do you think that the future of
Comedy is going
downwards nuclear Holocaust well there
are more funny comics now than ever
before
yeah but the world's gonna blow up why
would the world blow up
I blame the peers
that's a good reason clearly
anti-Semitism I think stand like live
stand up is going to end up where jazz
is now does anybody want to trade a you
know what I mean it's gonna slowly go
away it's gonna be like a beatnik thing
to go I need a sheep no for the next 30
Years Phil clearly not wow it feels like
I don't know you need a sheep I need a
sheep I mean there's no way this could
keep going you don't want to trade you
don't have a shape well don't you see
the shows you're like yeah this is a
good show these people had a great time
no one has it Gareth
it feels like a good thing come on Han's
doing training it's like when you and to
show you're like there's that's that's a
money maker yeah I'll give you the wood
I stole back or that I stole from you
for a sheep hunt no
I have my turn then that's gonna be it
is that the ridge wallet you got on kill
tonics
yeah nice
foreign
okay
just making sure okay what was that it's
a seven Ridge was an older sponsor they
still sponsor the show
I feel like oh that was a lot a long
time ago yeah man
that was 500.
it was a while ago it's over here
well yeah oh yeah let's give me a card
fan amount
please okay the lighter one is the the
there's two lighter ones
little boy
I shouldn't have fanned it out
yeah you [ __ ] up you should have done
what you did to Gareth
um yeah I'm gonna pass it he put it on a
12.
hey
[ __ ] you I like how as soon as we
address nines like I placed it on a nine
just hasn't been a nine since oh now
there's gonna be nothing but nines way
to go so it was on eighth fellow come on
man right here
I know I was over there
can I place this now or I have to wait
till next turn
this is exactly what I was banking on
what do you mean what I just pulled it
can I play it now I development card no
extra yeah
I heard every moment of you like that
from the moment the bottle touched her
lips till it hit your stomach is what
that sounded like give me the dyes ASMR
yeah
alcoholic ASMR right here
acrylics Anonymous ten ten ten ten ten
cool ten I think it was a 10.
loses its mating after a while doesn't
it
foreign
rock and roll three
a lot of people don't want to give three
the credit it deserves for the number a
lot of people think
a lot of people think out About Dre
you can wear like the real thick Shady
dude
I like the real dad bud Slim Shady you
just look Shady
cut the fat you're shady that's what
they call your dick is a little shady
because it's always nice drugs are you
curious what I was gonna say
Gareth does look like he could be a
Grady y'all ever met a Grady before I
never read a Grady oh wait I have he was
like an old black guy
that lines up
okay well all right I'm just gonna calm
down now ah damn it
that's so much nobody here wants to
trade for a sheep I need a sheep hey man
I got wood
I got a ton of wood nobody it's the
worst card I just need a sheep
come on Hans give me a sheet
so what do you guys think about the uh
inflation going on Keynes racing games
chicken fingers today it was the first
time I was like what the [ __ ] is going
on man it's 9 50 now for a three finger
combo dude I you're gonna complain about
the prices in canes I was just about to
go there I was gonna doordash it today
it was thirty dollars thirty dollars for
a [ __ ] order of Kane's Chicken
Fingers man I was like dude I could get
PF Chang's for the same cost as these
chicken fingers how do you judge things
is PF Changs this is like two PF Changs
this this dinner is two PF Changs me and
my girl had our anniversary last night
it was like nine and a half PF Changs
because
it's [ __ ] expensive for what it is
it's like a little bit better than uh
you know your local Chinese place or
whatever but it sounds like a detective
uh a 23 dollars for a [ __ ] sesame
chicken I'm like what is why is this 23
dollars okay chicken for six dollars at
Costco what is what Payway yeah I've
been at Pei Wei before wait no I have
not where is it what is that no
all right let me see uh hanzino what a
Payway is no it's a Payway Philip it's
like a uh
Express version of PF Chang's all right
does anybody does anybody have any sheep
it's a fast food yeah what do you want
for it really oh wait no pay way before
I've [ __ ] been to a Payway before
yeah
yeah no it's it's all right it's
mediocre there's a place that's kind of
like Pei Wei called Sao and it has no
delivery fee and you don't have to tip
the people they only pay them a livable
wage it's crazy no those people are
Shackled the moment they get back to the
[ __ ] story they drive like a new
camera it's pretty sick gig dude to
deliver Chinese food it seems like they
just have to have a wrap over their car
that just says Sal on it like the whole
[ __ ] car is covered in the TSA I've
seen these yeah dude dude that [ __ ]
it's good it's [ __ ] good solid it's
like 22 bucks for like a big portion of
food
oh
what's your go-to Chinese place Panda
Express ah makes me shoot razor blades
right you need to get that checked out
razor blades it's already been checked
out it's colon cancer it's colon cancer
yeah they told me I said hey do you go
to the doctor puts a thumb in your ass
every time you go every time every
single time here Phillip yeah your turn
look I sprained my ankle he'd be like
bend over man we got to get two knuckles
in there to make sure it's not broken
fill up yeah it's your turn
five again
and I'm gonna play Road building which
played two New Roads as if you had just
built them
so is your like ass sort of like always
on fire
wait below what did you know I built two
roads no what did you roll though oh I
rolled um
hard to say eight
same pay attention
can I move this back over here no fine
uh what are you doing over there Phil I
get long description I wasn't fine with
it
you didn't ask me Hans lives here
okay fair enough
I'm glad you feel better about yourself
is this your room haunt
yeah I think you're gonna just make a
small bed so you're probably richer than
you Gareth yeah you are dude I'm really
happy for you I didn't think Gareth was
rich what's up are you done Gareth you
make money
do you guys use this room for like
crippling games that's what it feels
like a crippling gambling addiction
three Backyard Brawl happen today dude
I won my cover bet by a half a point
dude I was [ __ ] pissing [ __ ]
needles you do have you guys are all
picking [ __ ] up because I rolled a three
you rolled the three oh babe
who wants brick
I do you have wooden wheat
I got we I'll give you a wheat for it
you have Rock nope
I have wheat do you want it or not I'll
take it all right here we go
that's how that works it's called the
economy
kind of economy of Catan dude
you mean the katanomy
I'm trying to get at your
contain to me
if you know what I'm saying
we got 10 is what we got
so let's use a while
and I'm gonna build a road thank you
runs
appreciate you
know
what do I need to build this hey
Phillips here hey Sheba that's the
camera
do you want to uh how's it going hey you
can grab a chair
or a stool I'm sorry
yeah they might be using it
oh yeah
uh
Jesus
[Music]
here we go
get yours
rock and roll
you said you rolled a 10 yeah that's
exactly what I said he already picked it
up though all right
are you done with your turn I'm I'm so
done with my turn now
I built the seven yeah
give me one million all right
so I'll move it to Hans is nine
don't listen to them there's a seven so
let's see how many cards you guys got I
think kind of used all my cards Philip
is winning
how many cards you guys have said hey
guys
my bad
what are you guys
uh or do you guys play Katan
okay I'm gonna win this one real quick
no war
it's exactly like Risk yeah it's pretty
similar
seriously Monopoly whose turn is it is
it your turn no it's still my turn I
have to move the robber and also take a
card from 180.
no from Hollands oh well take it from
Holland
what do you want me to take it from Hans
so mean yeah it's unnecessary
richer than I am yeah just you take your
hands I mean no not that because they're
not there dude no don't listen to him
what it looks that's so stupid it does
look cool hold on don't let them tell
you what it doesn't look cool you
probably want to put it somewhere over
there put it on call it haunts is nine
of wheat because this one here yeah
it doesn't matter all right okay I'll
put it there hold on yeah why would you
do that that's so stupid they made me do
it do it somewhere else do it on one of
their numbers uh also let me get a card
Phillips winning I don't care
around me
two these mics worked pretty well too oh
[ __ ] let me see if I can get you guys
some mics
can I trade does anyone have any Wheat
still if you want this or no
no no we
train I got wood and I got wood and I
got clay and I [ __ ] that
damn I was saying anything in the truck
you give me wheat
Hans do you have any Wheat
no dude just take it take it take it
take it take his cards dude he said no
hey Gareth no you got you can't you
can't you can't okay I'll build two
roads then since I'm just the road dog
dude
no dude don't [ __ ] snitch on me when
he comes back in here dude I can't
believe he did that man yeah you want a
snitch on me
[ __ ] him he cheated earlier it happened
hey do you need a settlement on here to
get there are you just need a road right
you just need a road to the two roads to
build a settlement no you need you just
need a road to the harbor to get the
resources oh yeah yeah you got no no no
you got to build a settlement you got to
build a settlement over there you gotta
put yeah you got to put that land dude
yeah no I'm not duking you dude you
gotta go all the way there and then
place your foot down put in a flag on
the property let's give them something
oh you're over seven he said no I rolled
the two he wrote the two okay
I'm making a ball sack he has the balls
he has the longest road so he has four
points well but
um this longest road count if there's a
house in between the road
yeah it does if it's connecting if it's
still connecting are you sure I'm pretty
positive to that yeah I've looked it up
I'm looking it up now if the longest
kind of desperate has somebody else's
settlement running through it it still
counts right yeah no no okay so it's
gotta be yours I was wrong okay yeah
that's not surprising okay anyone have
wheat I need to wait for this
I don't have any I was asking for some
earlier
would you roll again funny we bring it
up again eight
[Music]
um
yeah I was there from two to like nine
yeah it was a slow slow day at the hotel
yeah
more like the slow tell [ __ ]
seven oh you're gonna be first
that'd be a good name for like a Chopped
and Screwed remix of hotel motel Holiday
yeah
oh
yeah it's a it's stored with the drum
set yes
Philip we're at War now dude
spread them
early on that's the receiver right yeah
now you turn it on
um
have you not used these yet
all right it's connected to number two
and it's getting audio right now
talking to it hello hello
move away from your mic though
hello
hello
it says they're both getting hello hello
hello can you not hear it though I think
it's I'm getting you through that
microphone and that's the thing give
them to them and see about it
hello
it worked for a second it sounded like
it turned off
it says it's going but
that's the earphone is there like a
switch on there or something
what's the chat saying all this is
happening it might just be very fun to
watch
Network who cares I know I'm just
kidding I care what do you want to do
whose turn is it are you done what yeah
um
keep talking hello what have you done
now can you hear it um hello you already
moved the rubber yeah or is it on that
one that's working oh I have to steal
yeah
you son of a [ __ ] Phil no you're still
yours isn't plugged let's see your cards
Dude right I'm stealing from you dude
you don't want to steal from me give me
yeah that's mine oh it's for both of
them
no [ __ ] that dude hello
dude I showed them to you
can't talk louder yes I can't talk
[Music]
lava Clips yeah
I mean we're just commenters on this
pretty much so
um so far Philip is winning yeah
everybody turn on Phillip
sorry all right whose turn is it are you
done yes
hello
just don't do it so loudly by the mic
two two
did you pick up your
so yours works does anybody uh yeah yeah
okay does anybody have any weed
because I don't
um
no weed as of now hey Phil if you have
any Wheat no I don't have any
huh
yeah I'm good then let me see your life
actually
Mike my check
is anybody
yeah
does anybody have any sheep
no no
no just treat them all right
why do you have wood
do you have wood below could it be
because it's only the left one I already
finished
the lineup I switched this to the right
one real quick yeah sure
no no difference
no difference
the watermelon is a game changer
right there all right Phillips turn yeah
we've been saying
tin again did I miss out on the
watermelon as a game changer
conversation okay
because it's really good that one's a
really good flavor
does anyone have any clay they want to
trade
or does anyone
that's my turn y'all no
pounds did you go thanks
here we go
seven
oh maybe it's set to all the way that's
the game function
the knot on the bottom yeah
the white one
what about the red one is that one
it's the right one dude that's the aux
volume
yeah
great and I'm stealing from you
you [ __ ] sack of [ __ ]
foreign
actual AV guy anyone
I'll just go for it shut up [ __ ] you
can't even have weed in most of Texas
this is getting cringe big [ __ ] boy
can't have weed in Texas LOL WTF yeah
this is live stream is cringe yes see ya
yeah I was just speaking his mind is
is
hey you were at Vulcan earlier
was I yeah the law
well I don't think I've ever been there
before dude okay
yeah
I apologize
eleven yeah
that's great news
everyone picks up on an 11. even you
Gareth oh man
um does anybody have any
Rock
depends if you have any Wheat I do I
don't want it either way
yeah we and wood
I'll give you one week for one rock no
thanks okay Phil if it's your turn
seven
how many cards does everyone have
five
four
Gareth how many cars do you have Grady
three all right
three is what I got sour candy always
makes me sweat if I can't have weed
nobody can like any sour candy I
apparently yeah no it does I don't know
why it's a fun
facts
son of a [ __ ] dude yeah it's my turn
let me see what's Pikachu hand real
quick [ __ ] you I bet there's some wheat
in there somewhere oh dude you guys want
to smoke this dude
smoke weed but you won't eat salad what
are your favorite hobbies
uh skydiving free diving
um I don't know heroin did you guys know
I used to do heroin it's a fun little
thing I it's a conversation story
comedy I guess man yeah that's a good
hobby why do you like it so much it
doesn't feel good but being on stage
feels good stuff I like it from
camaraderie Community a bit probably
doesn't feel as good as heroin right
it's enough that I got off of it for it
so in a sense a little bit
I mean I always want to relapse on
around Phillip though yeah whose turn is
it Philip ruins it
Phil makes me want to do more
seven
it's like uh it's because uh Philip
Seymour Hoffman energy what are you
doing I'm stealing from you you're gonna
get wood
you already touched that one you do look
like a kid from the basketball diary so
and assume Basketball Diaries I don't
know what that is something your
Christian mother made you watch oh I see
I don't know what I'm talking about is
that with Ray Allen now it's Leonardo
DiCaprio do I want that for what wait no
I need to wait who wants this for wheat
Leonardo DiCaprio sucks a wiener for
heroin in that movie Basketball Diaries
you have any rock on great movie it's a
great movie yeah it was a great movie
it's a great movie absolutely it has
he's doing it it's like a big heroin for
sure that is getting big it's an old
school movie
I like train spots over there doing
heroin and the baby dies I don't like
that they made a second one because all
those guys should have been dead yeah
spotting Tuesday's been like they all
died that's it
we're back with new opioid addicts yeah
they're doing like fentanyl now you know
like yeah
you got a shape yeah they're like uh
yeah they're like yeah hipsters I love
you immigrations
yeah I'll watch it I'll I'll get
triggered or whatever a little bit
better
uh 10
hey Phillip
do you think people get weird about
their Vapes
these costs like 20 bucks
they last forever though those are
escobars right it's a new Jewels yeah it
is and it's just as marketed towards
children too
we got fun playlists like here it says
Fuji apple it tastes like cigarettes
um does anybody have because I broke it
open again so it would keep going it's a
little trick actually I'm done Phillip
we can go
Carolina
uh yeah they don't want us smoking in
here though
that's a tin I don't know but so many
attempts
um well did I give it to you I thought I
put it right here
did I I think he did dude
you said it you set it down and you
picked it up I was watching you did 90.
I did 10. I need a clay you know what
I'm saying
that you put it right there yeah it
doesn't have any Wheat placement no no
one has wheat [ __ ]
no I don't have any Rock oh that sucks
everybody watch The Game of Thrones [ __ ]
no yes it was great it's like a real
dude it's like going back to the world
of the Game of Thrones
there's actually to this oh hell yeah
there's an ending to this one though so
I'm really stoked but while you were
saying it was an outline right when I
was yelling no no it comes from like a
like it's a history book that Jordan
Ryan wrote about like the history of who
wants brick I need wood well they're
full on books dude you probably like I
got you well it's not it's it's from
like an excerpt from a book it's a story
about like what happens basically but
it's not as long as it happens right you
know yeah yeah so all the major plot
points are lined up yeah all the kids is
a [ __ ] problems so they're gonna have
to work really hard to find a way to
[ __ ] it up but I'm sure they will
I have faith I thought to the first two
episodes really good after I watched the
whole like first show I was coming on
wasted all those hours only for them to
end it um like what did you roll
five five uh the dude I just don't like
the king we all seen the king's face
yeah
that's the point he's a weak King
I thought he was pretty cool single six
yeah no nine that he is he's a wee guy I
get that but like dude you gotta have
like a chiseled Jaw you gotta dude you
gotta have a chisel yeah you gotta
[ __ ] look good you gotta [ __ ] be
up there portraying a weak King do you
think they made him good looking it
wouldn't be as powerful okay so do you
think right there good looking guy
intentionally casting people at what
kind of inbred
I might turn
well I mean bread no I'm saying like you
know the chick from the show she looks
kind of remembering I can ruin them
there's like some kind of hot girl at
home with her eyes that are too like in
inside set and she's like oh my God
you're so close together who are you
talking about it's like he said that
everyone on Game of Thrones kind of
looks like oh [ __ ] I just [ __ ] up
sorry I was like you have to be from the
Deep Woods of Tennessee to be able to be
on Game of Thrones or Targaryen feudal
alcohol syndrome
um once again does anyone have any Rock
no dude all right in my turn then but
now what I'm saying is like uh
I don't know
sometimes people do you look at them and
you're like
they look a little inbred
but they don't have to actually be they
just like have a look where you're like
they could be though seven
and bro dude I mean yeah I'm from uh the
South so damn it there's a lot about you
know
so like do you think they're like when
they're casting people they're like man
uh he's a good actor but he doesn't look
like inbred at all and it's a problem
does anyone have when you're here you
should yeah like do you have Johnny
do you have wheat and alcohol sweet
what did you get well I don't trade with
Philip here we go this is a it's a wood
it's not a war with Philip the seat it
doesn't break go clean oh no
where is he gonna build it on the wheat
on the rock or the wood and The Rock
this I mean I would say dude on that
mountain dude represents
it's uh Springfield Illinois in my
country
what why always
wait where's Abraham Lincoln from again
in the wheat
that is so it has a rock
in the rock or what's important at this
point in the game man
yeah there's more weight if you don't
have any clay three you only have a
three on a clay that's nothing
are you done
no
you can't do that you can't do that
let's see if you don't do the rules you
don't yeah I'm done [ __ ] play with me
man
hey
[Laughter]
Hans Go Get Your Gun
it's always good to play with guns on
camera on the internet it always goes
well
there's no felonies
when you get a gun and bring it on a
podcast there's a video of a girl
shooting her boyfriend in the chest oh
yeah what yeah no way and she's just
like it's a complete accident
I gotta film myself shooting this person
yeah when we saw that girl that locked
her uh boyfriend in her [ __ ] little
suitcase in the suitcase yeah you know
about that this lady uh so I saw the
first thing I saw like he got suggested
to me on YouTube it was like the footage
of like the cops responding to the 911
call and they get there and there's like
her boyfriend like he was in a suitcase
and he's dead as [ __ ] and uh [ __ ] and
she's all like oh we were just last
night we just saw we were just playing
hide and seek and we thought it'd be
funny if he got in the suitcase but then
I forgot he was in the suitcase and I
fell asleep and uh I woke up and came
down and he was like this the cops were
like were you drinking at all she's like
no yeah it sounds like a very plausible
story well you want to trade for a week
oh no don't worry about Philippine trade
for a week who is she playing hide and
seek with I don't have any weep
all right no but no it was her her
boyfriend but then they were just
playing hide and seek from each other no
that's what this is the story she told
the cops yeah yeah but then like they
asked if I could go through her phone
and [ __ ] and then uh they looked on her
phone they found videos of her drunk as
[ __ ] recording him in the suitcase he's
like baby baby I can't breathe baby
she's all like this is for everything
you've done to me and [ __ ] like that and
like this dude they said he was in there
for at least 11 hours and he died of
positional asphyxiation what uh how did
he how did he get in there was she he's
probably got him drunk and he's like oh
yeah you know that fun game we all play
with the significant others
maybe she got him drunk and he passed
out and she stuffed them in there that's
horrible women are evil are you it's
your turn
I thought it was pretty cool honestly
well it's your turn okay there we go
that was coming from a really healthy
place
all right uh six you can put it on the
table by the way
it's possible
nine
oh wait I do get something now after I
built that house there I really [ __ ]
up not choosing the nine spot I'll smell
something burning
yeah actually the roost on fire baby
probably just cooking something let's
let's just hope it's that
um does anyone have any Rock
what do you have a trade
wood
[ __ ] no does anyone you have you want
wheat
no I do for a what rock okay but give
him a [ __ ] rock
rocker clay
give me the wheat and uh
have a sheep I have one wheat and I'll
give you that if you give me a clay
a sheep no I don't need a sheep I need a
clay or a rock dude
I think Gareth has acid reflux usually
when you're mad boobs rest on your belly
it is a good sign
[Laughter]
thanks I've been working really hard on
my uh self recently so your words of
encouragement mean a lot right you're a
person on the internet Harvey Weinstein
when he was 18. for the week I found out
recently I'm related to Charlie Sheen We
Will Rock You the teen and Weinstein is
spelled like the teen in 18 once yeah if
you're uh if you're uh it's a really
shitty way to find out you have AIDS
does anyone have any sheep
no I will trade you wood for sheep
there's a joke
fun stuff
six
hey do you have any hey Han do you have
any booze
yeah I got some um
there's more downstairs we got Angel's
Envy downstairs okay
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
so did you know that uh a lot of koala
bears have chlamydia capacity yes
isn't that weird you can't hold them
they'll give you chlamydia you can get
chlamydia from koala bear and their
fingernails like if they scratch you
it's toxic it's like poisoning it's like
how David Hasselhoff was popular in
Germany chlamydia is popular amongst
koala bears for some reason it just
clicks for them two
Gears of War
I wonder which one it is I hope it's
three
clearly five
I'm thinking
it's all good I think all you want
does anybody have any my girlfriends at
home tripping on mushrooms and crying Oh
I thought I thought they didn't work on
her like she's a really good girl yeah
every time okay so I don't have to go
she just did mushrooms for the first
time like a month two months ago
he cried oh well yeah does anybody have
any uh
no no I do what do you got what do you
need
I need weed what do you want for it
Rock
all right
that's what you're doing business with
you hey it's pleasure doing business
with you too all right I'm gonna build a
uh one of those uh cities
yeah
you roll a dice and that decides which
resources yielded that turn if you have
a property on that spot then you yield
and then you build things that give you
big three points and that's how you
build them
if you build like 10 roads or something
right five okay okay
that was a mushroom plus I might play
this game though I don't remember a lot
my people need weed or they'll stop
a lot of fun though
she's dreaming about how pretty this guy
is I'm not going wait a minute doesn't
she have a half Fantasia yeah
but she gets like she trips emotionally
she doesn't trip like video okay there
should be a study but how do you dream
about the sky if you can't visualize
things in your mind what's up
five
probably does anyone have any Rock
I'll trade you wheat for it
yeah does anyone have any sheep
yeah get set of cards around thanks
no wheat or no sheep sorry no
so where did you guys come from the
creek yeah how was it looked brutal yeah
it was that to the drop it right the
drop-in is a pretty good show it was
yeah it's packed it was did anyone stay
it's your turn home oh no no they all
left no but yeah close to the front but
yeah it was still yeah
alcoholics yeah
comedy
and I think that one couple that
happened here was the like only a couple
in the audience I'm glad I talked to him
I guess it was not fun but yeah
learned a lot about them
what six one God damn it
the man who invented Pringles had some
of his ashes put into a Pringles can
when he died thank you Michelle
who invented the Pringles can isn't it
just a can it's not the can that's the
most interesting part of a pringle it's
like the guy who invested a Segway
killed himself by driving into the Grand
Canyon on one right yeah yeah
you can't fit your hands in Pringle cans
that would have been the dopest
commercial ever though reference
that'd be like a Segway Super Bowl
commercial like it's just him like
six yeah
[Music]
I wanted to see if you got it
yeah
he's like [ __ ] brindle games
are you done I'm done
Bang
hey
say hey
I can't count
are you done one second
so uh what'd you do before the creek
does anyone have any claims no no
[Music]
inside the room out now outside what a
bunch of weak-willed producers so like
someone got stabbed near the place you
got canceled because of that that's
ridiculous I guess virtually he's
recording it off and they were like
making a big
it was in his shoulder like he did not
have to make that big of a deal what do
you get stabbed with Like a Knife did
you ask him or no no I just we saw the
blood and then later on I think Mikey
was telling us I was like yeah so why
did they just not want to do the mic and
they're just looking for any excuse I
don't know I don't know like that yeah
yeah I think so actually if you really
wanted to do it you would just do it
give me a wood it's already closed yeah
yeah
everybody's like you can't get stabbed
outside of the leader room yeah trying
to do my speed mic yeah or that guy only
gets stabbed
it was like when he doesn't get on the
list he's like I got stabbed
him yeah yeah
it's like that blood you the the bite
blood you know what I mean the Halloween
blood where it's like you can yeah
I'm done on my shoulder
so you that's the only thing you did six
[Music]
yeah
nice James was actually cool I like
James
Shader Schrader yeah I don't know his
last name but the guy that we were doing
the podcast with the son's friend he's
from San Diego yeah he was cool yeah we
saw him at both places and yeah
he did he did talk a lot of [ __ ] about
you the whole time though go ahead no
I'm [ __ ]
he actually did talk [ __ ] about you
Phillip so he doesn't know me I know
that so if he did that
don't make me start a beef with a comic
I don't know that will obviously win
because I have zero clothes
fight him Philip physically do you think
I could beat him oh my god I've never
seen the guy why Jerrell yeah you can do
it yeah
I'm good dude I think you can take
Hans looks like he knows how to wrestle
or something nah dude you got it man you
got this yeah go attack me physically
little
sad little man I would just uh I would
no I just need more turned on five yeah
we got a five you never know if there's
a conspiracy to eight to lose when you
start doing good your friends start
turning them back on you
yeah I've noticed that ever since you
moved to Austin yeah does anyone have
any Rock I'm gonna ask that question
again no
all right I didn't want to do this this
turn but I'm going to have to
the two Road thing again
so just to make sure no catch up
the two Road thing God you're just
lengthening this road
what do you have five points
you couple all off you are trying to
make balls at this and then I got the
you're plenty taking you can't play too
at the same time oh you can't yeah
I didn't know that I would have played
that one first do you want to play that
one first
director
did I roll the dice yeah
yeah it was an eight
seven
oh
I'm above you so did you watch any of
the drop in or did you just go up yeah
Marcus so oh forget what his last name
Marcus went up there [ __ ] killed
that was good let me see it
I see him what
Jesus I'm sorry
was it a wheat you're more statistically
it should have been a week
or you don't cough
it's kind of hot in here you guys want
to turn on the fan
yeah I was sweating earlier I thought it
was because I was fat we got a metal fan
it looks dangerous nice you cut cheese
with that [ __ ] yeah it's gonna be final
destination
put a trampoline under it
[ __ ]
all right I had my turn and Jolie a
carrots
yeah and it's on it's like
an angle it's really moving the air
see now you handed The Joint to me
though that's this is
two
okay
hello hello okay
is there any way to turn my headphones
down a little bit which ones are yours
the ones that I was just fiddling with
yeah
is that good yeah thank you
um hello hello
um does anybody have any brick
do you have Rock where are we what do
you want for it yeah
I got wood
funny because when I asked for clay
she said you didn't say brick he said
it's been a while because
so no
body likes it I got wood
yes or no I don't want it no man all
right Phillips
five again
five oh yeah gotta five again
does anyone have any clay or brick I
will give you whatever your heart
desires I want Rock and wait
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] look at this
Phillip is in demand right now
Philip's a hot boy well it's completing
is
getting up there
I think you also need two settlements or
three what's the can you what can I
place that there or no place what I can
do that
what is that like a house no you can't
do it no you can't be dessert you got to
put it on the uh yeah
you can't [ __ ] you there
no I'm fine
I'm fine and that's two of any resource
for a brick yeah
for it no two brick for any resource I'm
gonna play the Euro plenty
pick up some
I've seen
oh man it's a tough one
all right
can I build it still or no they just
gave me the dice okay go ahead and belt
it's just a road
place your robe
wherever it goes
have you guys watched
The House of the House of the Dragon
why why are you laughing we talked about
this a little while
yeah I know but we didn't really get
enough yeah we did I couldn't get like
15 minutes in I was a little tired so it
wasn't good for that
of your sheep or half the Sheep over
there no dude so the king the king
doesn't look like a king this is where
we we left it on that and he's saying he
was a peacetime King and that's how he
should be but at the same time dude like
I want the guy to look good I want him
to have them not saying he's a piece the
king isn't hot enough for you it's not
hot enough also
immediately murdered his wife viciously
spoiler alert dude
first of all
actually it's a one we're talking about
the first urgency I know but come on man
it just came out
I it came out two weeks ago at this
point get over it oh yeah two weeks it
was like ten years and now yeah it is
absolutely man and I'm not even giving
away the longest episode I just hate
that the dragons look like [ __ ] dragons
look like [ __ ] they spin a bunch I'm
really interested in this Lord of the
Rings show they spent a billion dollars
on it with a B they're definitely making
their money back
seven 250 million just on the rights
six million just on the right
is Jeff Bezos anti-Semitic
Holland uh can I get a card well he is
bald
yeah
it's true and white
okay what do you roll again
yeah baby
um
let me let me turn them the other way
uh
yeah
but uh I don't for whatever reason it's
flipped so yeah I flipped it I thought
it'd be better okay whatever the guy who
ever asked for it was like what the [ __ ]
man dude he wanted all the numbers but
evil app well they were all like
pointing out every which way so they
yeah some guy was like can you Orient
them what did the what is the chat
saying
would you mind orienting the number
tiles for the camera LOL bless you to
Tony Rose Gareth
Gareth needs sheep I think they meant to
say sleep
I'm wide awake
would you roll
seven that's right and he put it over at
12.
hey it's make sure you don't get that
[ __ ] Stone
hey say it again baby
all right I'm uh
I'm gonna go ahead and build a couple
rods
yeah if y'all want I can ruin the whole
Targaryen line like how the whole Show's
gonna go I know I've like looked into it
already actually don't do it I'm not
going to
don't be that cut I am not
so what do you think about Game of
Thrones philosophically and what it
means to our culture and why it was
produced and the time that it was
sex and violence cells period that's why
sex religion yeah that's literally all
those things politics sex religion it's
a period piece about those things
all right there's a [ __ ] that's really
good at math
and a lot of people talked about the
titties I thought when they really when
they put that bucket on that dude's
chest with the rat in it that was the
hottest part oh dude there's some really
hot Parts wait when did that happen
that's when Ramsay like season four I
think it doesn't happen like an action
movie or something like a fast and
furious movie so they put the bucket on
the chest and then they light a fire on
the bucket so the rats are like oh [ __ ]
let's get away from the hot metal the
only place is into this man's chest yeah
they can and they can scratched yeah
they can scratch anyone have any wood
I got wheat
nah got two wheat
yeah wait wait so who got it who got the
rat chest thing that's a no to the two
wheat I can't remember that way your
character on Game of Thrones some [ __ ]
too weak for wood
dude uh no the worst was the whole thing
with what's his face where he got his
dick cut off oh let's be honest Beyond
yeah dude we kind of deserved it though
I never every time
no not his dick though
he deserves some punishment but yeah it
was a little rough I thought it was a
little bit over the top sometimes you
gotta cut off somebody's dick
somebody mouths off to you it runs away
because they're scared of you and you
know I rolled an eight let their dick
and balls off
wait he cut his balls off too yeah yeah
he went too far
he wants brick I do it for what you have
wood
or wheat
or Rock
I'll give you a rock for a brick okay
we don't have anything
there we go
I need wood
if someone wants to give me wood I will
give them wheat oh wait a minute you're
about to get canceled
brick Gareth
giving you words
I need to stop trying to be funny no uh
I'm good on the prick
wait what do you want to trade for it
wheat or rock or wood
one three
oh yeah
it's so intense I know yeah do it smoke
it like that though
all right oh Jesus Christ
Jesus do you want to yeah I don't know
you're gonna like your marvelous
Marlboro
let's go on yeah I thought that was a
permanent marker this it's a standard
movement nine nine
pick up a wood thanks appreciate you
guys
hey Phil did you still want to trade a
wood for a week
hey brother why is that what you're
trying to oh yeah brother
it was much more cultured than that
hello head to the yes brother
you sound like uh
sound like an Arab trying to fit in uh I
have everyone at my uh everyone at my
job
like all the managers one is Italian for
like character Italian he's like I love
Ray-Bans it's this thing got a French
one and then a Ukrainian manager so it
feels like when I'm like if you shift
feels like a un meeting
you're done
I am my turn
I like the world that they portray In
The House of the Dragon
it's like okay
it's like Newtonian physics
a guy with a big sword is gonna Crush
you but here it's like oh that that guy
is in charge of marketing for Conoco
Phillips
like it's hard to tell who has power
and it makes sense is that makes
physical sense here it's like nuclear
physics and you know like the TV runs on
whatever you never know how anything
works but there you're like oh the strap
goes under the horse you're tighten it
we have an awesome magic sets you don't
know the magic words yeah magic is just
magic you don't have to think they've
never cleared the magic up in the first
time travel [ __ ] like whatever all right
I'm gonna get mad I don't want to get
mad the uh the grand man it seems like
the Grand Master there what is it the
grand Mister what is it the grand Mister
Grand maester is it the maester the
maester yeah no he's always a pedophile
every single for 200 years he's not a
pedophile 200 plus years here's the
pedophile in the show or at the Catholic
church I mean I think it works both ways
right like what's the offender it's just
too much power we had all of his little
bike he always was taking the little
boys into his room no he was [ __ ]
yeah the spider was yeah he was [ __ ]
hookers he was [ __ ] growing hookers
no but he was a eunuch so he didn't have
it no no no not very spiders
pretty sure he was a pedophile right no
no no he liked he liked he got killed by
children well he liked young girl
opposite he liked the young ladies which
still makes you like a little laurenti
barrier
he likes little girls so what did you
hear about win from Arcade Fire